today is President's Day which means
that we have off the uh the show there's
no show today and the studios are closed
down which comes as a shock to me every
year when I remember again that for some
reason we have off for President's Day
nobody knows why no one of the daily
wire knows why they give us off for
President's Day of all days but they do
and we're not going to complain about it
but then again I actually never have off
because we need to feed the content
machine and today uh and for the content
machine we're actually jumping into a
time machine there are a lot of memories
from this show so we're gonna go take a
look back at some um some moments of the
show and what we're interested in is not
like what I'm saying because who cares
about that but some of the objects and
things that are in the background as as
this show has traveled literally from my
car to a house to a studio some things
that are now part of the the show's lore
I suppose so we'll just uh we'll just go
through these kind of I don't think
we're going in sequential order exactly
but just going to take them as they come
so yeah first we have this is back when
I was I had graduated from the car
anyway but I was in my my house in the
studio we set up and I called a studio
but really was just like the core it was
actually the corner of our uh bedroom is
where we set this up and as you can see
there the crutches from when I uh tore
my achilles now the thing about that is
this is back in what was this 2019 I
guess I tore my achilles I was I went to
a kind of a bachelor party weekend my
good friend of mine was getting married
and so he got this house and it was like
a lake Deep Creek Lake in Maryland and
then I come home from that weekend
hobbled and injured which makes it sound
like some crazy things happen when
actually that's not the case at all we
just played pickup basketball and I'm
old and middle age now so and playing
pickup basketball I tore my achilles
totally ruined the weekend by the way
they had to like they had this is this
is the you know the middle of nowhere
basically so it's like they got driving
an hour to a hospital and I can't do
anything for the rest of the weekend
because I'm uh because I'm crippled it's
just completely ruined it
um and I was on crutches for a time
after that and also you know I got home
I think this was on like a Monday and I
got home and uh and I was severely
injured you know there was a week in
between when I tore the Achilles and
when I actually got the the the uh the
surgery to repair it because actually
when I went to the hospital which was
this rundown like Rinky Dink Hospital in
Deep Creek Maryland and when I went
there they told me that it wasn't torn
and that it was just uh it was just a
sprain and they gave me some some
Tylenol and said go home you're fine and
so I
sat with a completely torn Achilles for
a week until I finally went to a
different doctor they said oh no it's
totally shredded and we need to do
surgery but anyway I remember coming
home and I I called up the god king
Jeremy boring and I said I'm
horrifically injured I'm in a lot of
pain I need to take a couple days off
and he said well you could still sit
can't you you don't do the show while
standing I said you're right so I sat
there and I had my I think I put the
crutches there as like a small Act of
protest to show everyone look what
you're making me do but I don't think
anyone felt sympathy uh next we have the
globe you know the famous Globe I've uh
I've had a do we have any gloves on the
set right now how do we not have any
Globes somehow we've moved past the
Globes this was the one thing you know
the globe thing is when I was doing
these shows in random spots of my house
and I was a little bit jealous that all
the other shows on The Daily wire uh
they were all in Los Angeles and I was
on the east coast and they all they had
real Studios and all the fancy equipment
and so I needed some way to Spruce
things up a little bit to class it up
and bit and so I thought what better way
to do that than with a globe
also you can see that a mess of a
bookshelf behind me that my wife would
always complain about and she said it
looks terrible in the shot but I I
disagreed you know at the time I thought
I think I think it's good look you know
what it's a she said yeah you got to
decorate the book it's on camera every
day you got to decorate it better you've
got to organize things make it look less
messy and I said no this is an authentic
bookshelf this is a bookshelf that's
actually used like I actually take books
off that shelf and read them
that was my thought process looking back
on it now
it doesn't look a little messy there
appears to be some sort of what is that
bottle in the background all in the
background I see some sort of looks like
a medicine bottle of some kind is that
like Robitussin I don't know what that
is uh and then we have well this is now
we're going all the way back to the very
early days of the show when I was a
homeless Drifter going from town to town
in my car I would usually have this book
bag
in the background of the shot and the
reason is that I I it wasn't like any
thought problems it wasn't decorating
the set or anything it wasn't much of a
set to decorate this is what it meant
for me to go to work because meant I was
grabbing my book bag
hopping into my car and I was finding
some random spot usually it'd be a
Walmart parking lot and I would just sit
there and do the show but I had to move
around quite a bit you know I had to
work with there's a lot you don't take
into you know you don't think about
before you start doing a show in your
car it's like the sun it's also the fact
that I can't roll the windows down
because then everybody can hear me as
they're walking by they hear me ranting
about whatever Easter
is on Sunday
what and in that sense I got to keep the
windows rolled up also that way you
don't have the ambient noise but then it
gets really gets really hot sometimes in
the summer there are some shows if you
go back to the early shows you'll see
some shows where I'm in a um it appears
to be that I'm in like a parking garage
which I was because I needed some shade
you know from the Sun
and to be able to keep the windows
rolled up this next one yeah that's my I
went through this brief odd phase of
wearing a bracelet and I don't know why
or what I was thinking I'm wondering if
this was even photoshopped did I really
do that
a moment of temporary insanity I'm not
exactly sure I really don't know I don't
remember ever putting this thing on is
that even me is this a deep fake I don't
believe that's me I never worn price
this is this got slipped in there I
don't believe it and then we finally we
moved to a real Studio this is where you
may remember the sloth in the tumbler
that had another thing now I'm just
remembering all these things that have
somehow disappeared from the set that I
want back yeah I want the globe back
there you guys hear me in the control
room I want to Globe back I don't know
why we don't have a globe
and I want the sloth back that's the
slot that we had in our tumbler and that
was from that was a gift that I received
in our 12 Days of Christmas series that
we did shortly after moving here now we
came to Nashville and it was right
before the Christmas holiday okay we got
another gift here uh this one from a fan
in the UK apparently I have at least one
fan in the UK I've got one fan there
I've got two or three fans here that
makes three or four total
um
let's say
slow Brew sloth
T infuser
I don't even know what that is
okay so it's just a sloth they
well here's the note says greetings from
across the pond you recently reviewed
Chelsea Handler's stand-up comedy
in which she called slow people koalas I
think she meant to call them sloths
enjoy this tea infuser as a reminder of
your listeners in the UK
well my listeners in the UK suck it
would seem apparent
striking out again on Christmas
and I guess the idea is that the joke
was supposed to be that all the gifts
were terrible but I actually liked most
of them and I like that little sloth too
now he's gone no one knows where he is
and then obviously who can forget the uh
the the alien now the interesting thing
about this alien that I still have on
the set
and this is this is an ongoing fight
here about I insist on keeping this
alien somewhere and he moves all around
and for a while he was outside that
window uh but and then I think that they
just now now that I'm realizing I think
that they they move the alien off the
set completely so what they do is I'll
make a stink about I want my alien back
and they'll put it somewhere and then
they'll wait for me to forget about it
and then they'll take it away
um until I remember and I say I want my
Elite this is this is push and pull that
goes on and now with aliens in the news
and UFOs all over the news
um I think we need this alien to have a
prominent place on the set once again
like he did for all that time the other
funny thing about this alien is that we
got it we put him on the set we had him
with the banjo it also part of the theme
Here is I'm not very observant and so it
didn't occur to me until months later
that this may be a gay pride alien uh
we're not exactly sure it's got all it's
got the colors of the rainbow so we
don't know is this a homosexual alien
showing his his uh Pride nothing wrong
with that if that's the case
I'm not going to judge the aliens for
their lifestyle choices mainly because I
don't want to be incinerated
you might you might call it a galleon
[Music]
that was my joke too I just thought of
that
uh finally what's the last one okay well
this is something on the set that I
never even knew about but they told me
about and you can see there
um that cup which I have here now
this is I'm told in my notes this is
McKenna's cup actually what they told me
this is the claim this is the story that
I heard that I'm not sure I quite
believe what I was told is that this is
a cup I'm pretty sure this is what Sean
told me this cup is from 1776 and I'm
looking at the cup and I think like it's
a nice cup I don't think it's from 1770
also it says 1776 on it and I don't
think that in 1776 they're making cups
and just saying to themselves this is
going to be a really significant year we
should put that year right on the cup
McKenna when was this cup made was it in
you have no idea she has no idea what
the cup was made well let's just say
this is a cup
scratch all that the really crazy thing
is that for so long on the set we had a
cup from the year
1776 sitting on the set that is true
history
[Music]
um
from the Matt wall show